that this would be and every time i've
said the lock it's been wrong but i'm
gonna say this is my lock of the week
okay
urban meyer
and the jacksonville jaguars have had a
disastrous week
urban meyer was in a bar
chick is dancing all over them
she gets no [ __ ] nobody nobody says
anything about the guy that filmed it
the [ __ ] rat okay go ahead yeah the
guy's filming it he's sitting there
apologizes to the team doesn't fly with
them stays in and gets caught out with
family and then out drinking again
doesn't fly with his own team to me that
says disarray and the tennessee titans
are coming he went out boozing again he
went out boozing again dude i am taking
the tennessee titans minus four to the
[ __ ] bank okay i think you're totally
reading it wrong paul
just for the [ __ ] fun of it paul
i'm gonna say it's jacksonville florida
in the [ __ ]